on what's up
I hate this this is annoying
yeah like that up se7 Creek we're on the
other side of here and then here there's
like there's no what happened
I was in lap
[Music]
love it
that's creepy
[Music]
crap
oh man it was this one wasn't it
ah come on I'm stuck
let's use this course huh
by the way
[Music]
everywhere
oh right why not why not
this is where you go huh okay I'm pretty
bad sense of direction
he's I guess well sounding me like the
Greek meal
so let's find the gate it should be here
somewhere yeah that's completely wrong
oh my god me something well most times
whatever
[Music]
yeah it's got to be here somewhere
I'm here oh my god there should be a map
of things holy cow
now let's walk forward right
where am i walking back now I'm so
confused it's so difficult
I need break the line I guess
beyond this door oh [ __ ] that's not even
a lot this is a room by the way that
smell like stop there that you stupid
arm
stop no edit it's so annoying the crack
oh man supposing okay it's not working
to get me I mean yes well thought of
something
oh man there's a game there isn't it
our chemical please don't do something
scary all right I'm just gonna pick this
up wait
all the subpoenas guys
yeah it's definitely the penis guy I
don't trust the penis game though
I don't trust any guy with a penis
anyway Ward's I'm standing in the
lightning end line oh I'm so whoa I need
[Music]
where do I go
haha oh crap he's gone
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] bro bro bro bro bro bro
bro bro bro bro we can settle this
missile in uploads left right left right
you can have the peace guy I don't want
it
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I [ __ ] found my way out I
didn't even mean to do that how the [ __ ]
did I survive that holy Sh
[Music]
bottle blood but we still okay so now we
put that in there right
[Music]
that third
yeah it's done
[Music]
whatever
makes her blood and Emma Gaston
chemicals volatile mix well set it was
our case
whoa
let's do it
[Music]
any suction power game whoa all right
sweet let's continue our journey
there's a key
oh man what's going on we pass out
I wish I had something to light it out
well we got a kid these fine
wait listen there or something
oh [ __ ] thanks it's fancy oh this is
where the game sorry I guess this I
don't know if I should be glad or if I
should terrified discovery like this
would have my name in college textbooks
but I doubt I'll live long enough to see
first edition this is a sacred place of
gargantuan labyrinth for ritualistic
sacrifices to appease the Aztec god of
discord the jagwire Ted Scott Limpopo he
is described as a volatility with the
power to cure all diseases forgive all
trespasses and free men of the mortal
destiny instead of choosing the blessing
entity with his divinity the Jaguar God
deprived us for the sake of his
amusement it is said that Ted Scott
lopaka is the beginner of war his name
means we who are in slaves
all priests would each choose a limb to
bind then but v plunge a knife to the
sacrifice and carve open his or her body
removing the heart while it still beat
soundly he would place the organ in a
bowl and toss the body down from the top
of the temple hasty the head would be
removed and displayed this temple it
belongs to him I have managed to
ignorantly stumble my way far into it's
hard and now as the last shred of my son
begins to vanish and I finally turn to
run I find myself caged as I face my
executioner now the routine of writing
in a journal soothes me informally as I
come to the end of this entry and I
raise my head to the dark I see
something stirring coming to take my
heart there's nothing
shut up so that was it
we got a funny though maybe that's the
end of their game like you go got it
there's you bunny well I was gonna say
I'm gonna keep the bunny but
let's go in there again I guess whoa
a few days confused as always god dammit
oh wait what is this what
that wasn't there before what
what I escaped so confused so I'm taking
a break my head hurts
[Music]